[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAKE VANDERPLAS: Hi, and
welcome to this video series
on Google Colab.
I'm Jake VanderPlas, and
I'll be your guide today
as we look at what
Colab is all about.
Google Colab is an
executable document
that lets you write, run, and
share code within Google Drive.
If you're familiar with the
popular Jupyter project,
you can think of Colab
as a Jupyter notebook
stored in Google Drive.
A notebook document is composed
of cells, each of which
can contain code,
text, images, and more.
Colab connects your notebook
to a cloud-based runtime,
meaning you can execute Python
code without any required
setup on your own machine.
Additional code
cells are executed
using that same
runtime, resulting
in a rich, interactive coding
experience in which you
can use any of the functionality
that Python offers.
For example, here we define
a variable containing
a range of 10 numbers.
In the next cell, we
loop through this range,
printing the square
of each number.
For convenience, we use
the Shift-Enter shortcut
rather than the Play
button to execute the cell.
Cell outputs are not limited
to simple text, however.
They can contain any number
of dynamic, rich outputs.
For example, we can search
Colab's built-in library
of code snippets and insert code
to create an interactive data
visualization.
This particular
visualization is created
with Altair, one of several
third-party visualization
libraries that Colab supports.
Colab notebooks can be
shared like a Google Doc,
and for this purpose
it's useful to use
text cells to provide a
narrative around the code
you've executed.
Text cells are formatted using
Markdown, a plain text document
format that's
rendered on the page.
Markdown format is
simple and powerful,
allowing you to add
headings, paragraphs, lists,
and even mathematical formulae.
If you would like to share
your notebooks with others,
you can do so via
Google Drive sharing
or even by exporting
your notebook to GitHub.
The notebook is stored in
the standard Jupyter Notebook
format, and so the
notebooks you create
can be viewed and executed in
Jupyter Notebook, JupyterLab,
and other compatible frameworks.
The convenience of
sharing notebooks
means that you can
find and explore
many interesting
notebooks around the web.
One useful collection
is the Seedbank project
at research.google.com/seedbank.
For example, the Neural
Style Transfer seed
shows how to use deep
learning to transfer styles
between images and
includes a link
to a Colab notebook where you
can run and modify the code.
To learn more about Colab,
visit colab.research.google.com
and find the Welcome
notebook, where
you will find links to
tutorials and other info
about Jupyter and
Colab notebooks.
You can also find
the remaining videos
in this series, which will
explore Colab in more depth.
In the next video,
my colleague Lawrence
will explore how to install
TensorFlow using Colab
and how to use
different runtimes
to access things like the GPU.
See you there.
Hi, I'm Jake.
I'm a software engineer on
the Google Colab project,
and we've got lots of great
videos for you about Colab.
So feel free to hit
that Subscribe button.